et maintenant tajani
qu'on ne compte pas sur malia
bonjour marie billa il a sa carte de
bons clients open il a vu ses seins
randonneurs du népotisme à ces deux
petites longueurs victoria cette carte
tu reviens quand tu veux même quand t'as
pas de promo certains tapent à de
méchantes et déjà la cas alors venir
jean-marie bonne année ah oui bonne
année bonne santé c'est s'est bien passé
son réveillon ouais il attend beaucoup
et jean- marié à vous avez fait quoi
pendant les fêtes la manche et ben eager
dogues j'y suis encore
ouais ouais je suis l'île maurice a au
moment où je te parle
c'est quand même étonnant et c'est super
un vraiment ça que je me régale et vous
avez pris jean marie bigard des bonnes
résolutions pour l'année 2004 déjà
commencé depuis deux jours je tiens à le
dire quoi bah pas au niveau des freins
vient comme moi des bonnes résolutions
oui non non j'en ai toujours eu plus
donc que ça continue quoi si la cie
l'année est aussi bonne que la fin de
celle là en armes est énorme
le dirlo sur tf1 10 millions de
téléspectateurs louis incroyable
c'est d'ailleurs maintenant à tf1 il me
regarde comme une comme une friandise
comme un peu comme le dernier chocolat
ma chérie sur le plat si c'est non
j'étais très content et très ému parce
que j'ai adoré faire ce petit téléfilm
vicky les marchés comme ça si ingrate
mois merci le lot et qui les marchés
comme ça à ce point c'est henri cadot et
tout le dvd toi ben on a frisé les
800000 dvd dont commandes même si on va
pouvoir en fabriquer assez c'est
extraordinaire tout ça c'est des cadeaux
à mes yeux de la vie donc si ça peut
continuer je suis mais alors on va
essayer de quand même de prendre une
bonne résolution tous les deux jean
marie parce que chaque fois que que vous
venez dans une émission que j'anime
c'est ce termine toujours par un
scandale
donc j'espère que cette fois ci on va on
va éviter le scandale c'est pas dire je
regardais un petit peu il ya plus de dix
ans on avait eu des reproches du csa
tous les deux dans une émission qui
s'appelait double journée ah oui grâce
au passage il y avait le lot une
prostituée qui demande ça s'emballe
elle est quand même plus nette à mes
yeux qu'une secrétaire qui sert de ses
fesses pour avoir une augmentation ya
l'épreuve cédant ya dix ans le csa avait
trouvé ça terriblement vulgaire ou
grossier peu importe d'ailleurs
maintenant je dis moi en amour je fais
confiance que que aux professionnels
bagdad les amateurs du moment l'amateur
elle trahit le casque bagua les toits
tandis qu'au moins de professionnels
ils ont fait une haie et s'il vend
souvent ça coûte pas beaucoup plus cher
que le resto le machin en plus j'étais
obligé de la gare des genres les clients
c'est moins drôle
voilà ça c'était le premier problème
connu ensemble ensuite y avait un
problème c'était la chanson le poil de
cul sur la savonnette et ça il avait
chanté ça dans double jeu c'était super
engueuler c'était comment ç'a commencé
très doucement
elle avait mis dans mon blues ou des
rêves bleus et des frisselle ma météo
c'était ses yeux quand il brillait on
était 2 elle a tout pris dans la maison
mon coeur ma vie mes boîtes de thon et
m'a laissé comme un adieu une chose
d'elle qui frise un poil 2
ce massage net et sa politique planent
est voilà donc en cet effet on avait été
convoqué avec laurent baffie a le cuir
on avait fricoté avec le rend chez le
patron de l'époque et hervé bourges donc
on était assis en face d'hervé bourges
avec laurent tous les deux et à maman
bourges a fait comme ça et laurent lucas
président vous avez fait un petit rototo
là va pas arranger vos histoires après
bon il ya eu l'histoire de toujours
ensemble à chaque fois un l'histoire de
l'homophobie là quand vous avez dit en
parlant de bo sexuelles deux mecs qui se
bourrent le cui toute la journée ça pas
plus ah ouais le nom à ce que j'ai vu
c'est si beau temps de le tourner le
vent bien fait j'ai dit mais il courait
le propos j'avais dit que j'avais été
super sommes j'avais juste dit katia de
deux trous de balles de deux
bistouquette tu mélanges un moment ou à
un autre
voilà une liste d'huguette qui va
rentrer dans un trou de balle que y'a
rien de diack saad a imaginé
professionnel je suis pas bégueule ne
savez peut-être pas que j'avais écrit
avec bernard 10 mai un album complet qui
s'appelait chansons qu trois points
rieuse v a le cul de minceur leurs
engrais des bordels et c'est un album
qui est introuvable aujourd'hui est la
dernière fois donc j'ai prévenu mon cher
l'igas encore pire c'est sur la
palestine
donc l'histoire ce soit à préparer quoi
je regardais qui ont ce trajet un jeu je
suis qu'amour tout est toujours non
violent tout ça alors on va faire un
petit test pour voir justement dans quel
état d'esprit vous êtes jean marie
bigard par exemple pour vous une fille
qui couche avec plein de mike sais c'est
quoi pour vous une fille qui couche est
le plein de mecs que ben c'est une fille
qui est sympa
bien qu'il progresse depuis l'histoire
est une fille qui couche le premier soir
c'est quoi pour vous jean marie pour lui
c'est un alain oui c'est une vie qui
gagne du temps et ça et vous regarde en
premier chez une femme pour garder quoi
maintenant si on la voit arriver de loin
évidemment petite idée sur la silhouette
s'est laissé les yeux ouais par exemple
doivent victoria je regardais je ne sais
pas je regardais je me caressait dans la
loge
on va garder en vie triste les dans les
yeux il ya à peu près tout quoi envie de
la regarder dans les yeux
le dj vie dans les yeux quelle est la
première chose jean marie bigard que
vous faites au réveil après mais
d'augmenter les coûts avant je fais mes
prières que tu me crois ou non je fais
me prix acquittés remercier je fais une
prière à dieu et je lui demande que
toutes mes paroles que toutes mes
actions tout soit le plus sacré le plus
pur possible et que j'essaye de regarder
les gens avec un maximum de mots d'amour
et toi j'essaye de lui demander de moi
de ne pas recevoir d'agression et
essayer de au moins de voir dieu dans le
coeur des autres
et qu'est-ce qu'il dit lui dans ces cas
là dieu mais quand je dormais chez
jean-marie quand je faisais mon fils
c'était à côté du tournage j'étais
réveillé le matin par ces prix avancé la
connerie il est très sérieux très strict
s'il n'y a pas au moins un truc que tu
fais systématiquement tu n'as pas de
repères concerne chacun pour leurs fans
âges s'étaient laissés pas
systématiquement tout le problème des
prières tous les cépages et pas une
bonne nouvelle pour pour jouer tous les
autres c'est que on
on a mis au point fabrication depuis
c'est l'eau qui tue plus le manque d'eau
qui tue les femmes font 15 bornes aller
retour pour aller chercher de l'eau est
on en train de faire un puits le puits
sera au nom du copain le bruit à 1 puis
laurent baffie g séries puis un gouffre
alors il a fait rappeler avec et avec un
truc solaire donc pour mettre une pompe
à énergie solaire et qui pourrait
alimenter tout un village et donc j'ai
chopé tous mes copains et je leur fais
gaffe et un purgatoire et bats-toi tel 3
1 2 3 mois jusqu'à lundi au parquet puis
thierry ardisson et c'est ton puis à
tous sur mais comme c'est ton puis c'est
marqué dessus
il y en eut beau c'est marqué dessus
mais tu l'entretien ça peut coûter entre
500 à 1500 euros par an d'entretien
c'est vraiment un papa très cher qui
veut faire des est par contre à chaque
fois que tu te lèves le matin même si tu
fais pas ta prière tu dis merde je donne
de l'eau à tout un village à 300 400 ou
500 personnes donc ça c'est vachement
bien de faire des signes on continue
jean marie bigard pour tester un petit
peu vos intentions ce soit pour éviter
les scandales vous dites quoi quand
quand vous vous coincer un doigt dans
une porte
tamerlan jeu en principe la peintre il
fut soft non je dis à moi est ce que ça
s'appelait le mariage lontan quand je
l'aurai bien et quand il prend les
couilles dans la porte ils disent ça
dort lipopette votre jour ont préféré en
ce moment c'est quoi mon nom mon jurons
brochures et ouais c'est bien il est
dans la violence mais c'est bien bien
alors pour éviter que continue à dire
des conneries on va faire de la promo
donc il ya deux promos jean-marie vous
le savez ça quand même
oui le dvd du spectacle donc ils
s'appellent des animaux et des hommes
alors le déclic en fait quand vous avez
écrit ce spectacle c'est une phrase
l'homme et l'animal le plus évolué de la
planète et il devrait s'en féliciter
chaque madrelle tu savais pas que tu vas
voir